the Homeland Security Department says
there is no specific threat against
music venues in the US after the
Manchester attack police in New York
City and around the country this morning
are on heightened alert homeland
security says people may experience
increased scrutiny around public places
Don Dahler is in front of New York's
Madison Square Garden with details of
the US response Don good morning good
morning no one is on higher alert than
law enforcement here in New York City
security has been beefed up at
high-profile venues such as Madison
Square Gardens here overnight the NYPD's
heavily armed hercules units were posted
outside the arena NYPD officers are also
guarding the British Consulate in
Midtown and security will be ramped up
at major transportation hubs throughout
the state today other police departments
like the LAPD and the Chicago PD say
they are monitoring the incident in
Manchester earlier this month the US
State Department issued a travel alert
for Europe the department warned of
potential terror attacks targeting
tourist locations and high-profile
events a State Department official tells
CBS News they are closely following the
situation in Manchester the NYPD and FBI
have officer liaisons in the UK they
will likely visit the scene of the
attack in Great Britain and report back
to the NYPD's counterintelligence unit
Charlie thanks Don